ihr werdet nicht glauben wie viel Ernte
dieser Balkon abwirft höre so oft dass
Leute sagen ich kann ja kein eigenes
Gemüse anbauen weil ich gar keinen
eigenen Garten habe aber man kann selbst
auf einer Fensterbank oder auf einem
Balkon so viele eigene Salate Kräuter
Radieschen und so weiter anbauen sogar
Obst haben wir hier wir haben den
kleinen Apfelbaum wir haben
bärenstreicher auf dem Balkon hier haben
wir eine Kräuterecke gerade wenn man
sein Gemüse vertikal anbaut wie hier in
diesem gestapelten Töpfen oder in
unserem Salat Regal kann man aus einer
winzigen Fläche eine richtig große Ernte
rausholen